welcome everybody uh to this uh
follow-up session uh on metadata systems
for end-to-end data and machine learning
platforms uh my name is Alejandro
Salcedo and uh just as a reminder uh
today uh you will be able to find uh the
link to the slides uh in uh the corner
over here so bit.ly slash meta up
um so you'll be able to access not just
the slides but also
um the resources that are provided
throughout
a little bit about myself so I am
engineering director at Salon
Technologies uh a company focused on uh
providing products developing products
for deployment and monitoring of machine
learning models so we have one of the
most popular uh Frameworks uh for
machine learning deployment I'm also
Chief scientist at The Institute for
ethical AI which is a research center
for focused on developing and
contributing to Frameworks for the
responsible operation design development
of machine learning systems and I'm also
a governing council member at large at
the ACM
So today we're going to be delving into
the topic of metadata and uh you will be
able to uh come out of this session with
some uh idea of why metadata is so
important uh even as a machine learning
practitioners uh especially when dealing
with machine learning systems at scale
or with growing
um number of machine learning models
that you have to deal with so we're
going to be first covering some of the
motivations and challenges of metadata
in the context of data science and
machine learning we're going to be
talking about how
metadata is actually different when it
comes to machine learning models as
opposed to just data itself
uh the more traditional use of metadata
I guess and we're going to delve into
some solutions that we have
um quite excitedly been involved in to
tackle some of these challenges uh
namely we're going to be covering the
open inference protocol as well as the
open inference schema and finally we're
going to be giving a call to action for
practitioners to be able to uh get
involved with tackling some of these
challenges in metadata
so let's first talk about how it started
right how how machine learning
um started you know when when it was
kind of like just a bunch of tools uh
back in the day where you know when you
were going to actually
um train a machine learning model it was
about choosing a couple of different
toolings for your stack but now if we
see how it's going we have now a collage
of ever-growing tools that uh are set up
to be the best for X particular uh
specific area right and even
more confusing is that we're now
converging into acknowledging that there
is a need to adopt uh the best of breed
tooling for different stages of the
machine learning life cycle right so we
have now a challenge of a large number
of tools that are available at our
disposal with potentially growing
um questions of how to actually navigate
uh this uh ecosystem and more
importantly how to make sure that uh we
can still be not just sane but ensure
that we are operating and managing our
machine learning systems and our machine
learning models uh in in ways that are
robust scalable reliable secure and
responsible right
so we are now seeing as I mentioned
briefly a convergence into what is being
referred to as the canonical stack and
what the canonical stack basically
implies it basically says that with this
large number of machine learning tooling
um they can the consensus is is not that
organizations will just adopt a single
platform that is end to end but instead
organizations will adopt a best of breed
set of subset of tools for each of the
different areas in their machine
learning and potentially even different
tools for different groups right so
perhaps data science for marketing would
be different that for pricing than for
operations than for sales than for
different types of like you know
departments within an organization and
this is a very interesting tool that
allows you to visualize this so for the
different stages of the machine learning
life cycle experiment track
experimentation runtime engines code
versioning deployment model registry
what are the tools that maybe I could
like pick and choose and then see how
this would then interact across my
entire area
now
whenever we actually deal with the
end-to-end life cycle of a machine
learning model we are dealing with
different stages where of course if you
are a small data science team Perhaps it
is the same individual that is
performing all of these different stages
however when you have a large
organization with multiple different
business units and perhaps a very large
data science organization that
interfaces with different groups you you
are performing handovers of resources at
each stage or at each substage of the
machine learning machine learning life
cycle so throughout the data operations
the experimentation the
productionization the monitoring the
operation the operation and the use case
specific uh you know processes there is
a element of of resources and uh in this
case metadata that is being handed over
uh from one part to another so there's a
lot of considerations to take into
account now we're also seeing
that there is a move from what before
used to be referred to as uh the the the
the the Silver Bullet of
organizational data complexity which was
basically uh referenced through the
concept of a data Lake a central data
Lake and there was this dream that
organizations were going to be able to
adopt a central data Lake and perform
all of their operations within that
Central data Lake manage all of their
machine learning life cycles all of
their data life cycles within that
Central data Lake however what was what
uh organizations realized and what
organizations came into challenges is
that that centralization then becomes
not just a bottleneck but a challenge
because different domains may require
different specializations different
tooling different
um data products in order to function in
an efficient way and that's why now it's
moving into what is now referred to as a
data mesh architecture so it's still
true that it absolutely makes sense to
have uh you know that concept of a data
Lake but in the sense of just a lake of
data where you have all your raw data
but once you start are moving into your
you know bronze data sets your silver
data sets your golden data sets where
you're actually building data products
and you're actually having organizations
that are extracting value from data you
there is a need to have an embedding
capability and delivery that is
connected and agile connected in an
agile way with the domain itself and
this is where the concept of a data mesh
is coming out so you know this talk is
not going to delve into the concept of a
data mesh but it's it it will kind of
like uh reference to it of why there is
this need of this canonical stack right
and this canonical Stacks there is a
need for just multiple different tools
um at different stages of the machine
learning life cycle that actually Branch
out so now you have a broad range of
heterogeneous systems that you have to
deal with and with that comes some
challenges of metadata at scale right
when you're dealing with organizations
that are at web scale
you have complex challenges and
complexity and extensibility so this was
actually from a talk from uh uh uh the
the the team
uh that authored
um data Hub which is uh large-scale data
management system that came out of
LinkedIn and these are some of the
challenges that were highlighted of
metadata at scale so there is complexity
and extensibility challenges the fact
that there is this sort of like
decentralization uh democratization of
uh data products uh the need for best of
breed tooling the need for integrating
with SAS platforms the integration with
with open source platforms the need for
the different uh schemas of data in some
cases you know the benefits of like
Loosely types so that you can like dump
any sort of like data shapes or data
data schemas but also strongly typed in
order to actually consume and get value
from the data the challenge of schema
Evolution as as your data change changes
and evolves the challenge of extending
for particular use cases there are
challenges with scale and heterogeneity
right the relations of data whether it
is like graph data or relational
whenever you deal with massive scale and
you have like graph data you're you
perhaps are dealing with
um uh you know very complex uh queries
that may involve hundreds of millions of
nodes or vertices which may no longer
fit in a single
um you know
architecture you may also have
bottlenecks with database types whether
it is like transactional or noiseql or
key value um
queries and perhaps even like the need
for full text search right like a la
elastic search type type queries
then there is reliability right
um the the requirements that you have of
like system reliability at web scale but
also remembering that
um you know data reliability is
different to system reliability right
and it's there are challenges that are
very complex that actually defer uh to
that of the system reliability ones
there are challenges of real-time
synchronization across your different
broad range of systems uh zero downtime
requirements when performing like uh
data migrations full audit Trails etc
etc and what then this implies is that
when it comes to be able to deal with
your data through your metadata even
dealing with the metadata itself uh your
metadata may be as complex and as large
as your big data itself
right and then that that begs the
question of like when you perhaps look
at a system like data Hub your first
thought or my first thought was well why
does a metadata management system have
to have literally all the databases and
and have to have such a complex
architecture you know in this case
basically if you look at the data Hub
architecture having like uh
elasticsearch neo4j you know MySQL some
metadata crawlers that you know
connecting to Kafka for for streaming of
your metadata et cetera Etc and that is
because of that challenge that now when
we're dealing with metadata it's not
just metadata of a particular
um um you know set of models but it's
organizational wide and with different
modalities right it's like if you want
to perform
um Rich Text search or you want to
perform
um uh High throughput queries or whether
you want to perform relational
relational type queries uh this actually
needs some thinking of how it can be
tackled now if we extrapolate the
challenges that you have even data
metadata because so far we have been
talking specifically about the
traditional uh view of metadata right so
data metadata which is now being
referred to as data Ops so in this case
the the reasons why you would want
metadata of your data is for things like
data Discovery right it's like what are
the the tables that I have available
that I can consume to get value from
what is my schemas that are available so
I know how to deal with them what is the
versions of those schemas what are what
is that the ownership of the data what
is the taxonomies across my organization
of that data what is the lineage of the
data but once you're diving into ml the
current state of how we have seen
machine learning machine learning
metadata is it has been one-to-one
mappings with how we see data right so
that is basically what we have seen so
far like the concept of a model card
right the information about a a machine
learning model what what is the modality
what is the data that it was used uh
what are the the you know an artifact
itself that was created uh for for for
my machine learning model the different
versions of of artifacts the model
dependencies the the risks of that model
but now the the purpose of this talk is
to basically uh challenge this current
perspective and basically say how how it
is not enough and we actually have to go
beyond in order to understand and really
be able to tackle metadata for
production machine learning
and in this case when you're dealing
with operationalization of machine
learning you have to deal with the
intersection of data Ops and
microservice challenges right or system
systems web scale systems challenges
because now you're dealing with machine
learning service Discovery inference
data schemas
model data schemas right it's like how
do I consume a particular model if we
think of as models as perhaps like you
know you could think of it as a as a as
a database uh function or database
transformation where you can send a
particular data input and then you get
an output you want to understand like
well what is my available uh set of of
models that I can consume but now you
have to think about it not just as a
particular machine learning model and
not only just as a potentially a machine
learning pipeline but as a machine
Learning System right and we will dive
into what that means the system risks
the system ownership the system value
that we can extract from our operational
environments now let's actually ask the
question of what we're talking about now
as machine learning systems and not
machine learning models so let's take a
look at the the experimentation area
which is the more traditional kind of
production machine learning area that we
have seen this is where we perform
you know things like high parameter
tuning
um
distributed training evaluation of
models or just you know with with
different like ETL Frameworks etc etc to
produce basically artifacts machine
learning artifacts from training data
now we want to actually uh consume those
those artifacts uh we do that by making
those artifacts available for inference
right that could be done with you know
direct kind of manual productionization
or through continuous delivery
mechanisms which allow us to make those
artifacts uh consumable in a real-time
or batch manner but that doesn't stop
there right because now that we have a
operationalized machine learning model
we have a risk that we have to manage so
now we have to make sure that we are
managing that risk with the respective
observability
um the respective
um you know even also Advanced
monitoring which kind of involve even
further Advanced monitoring components
like drift detection and light detection
explainability models etc etc and now
every single thing that is going through
our production environment a production
machine Learning System we have to make
sure that all of that is actually
captured so that we can have
auditability reproducibility of the
inputs and outputs together with the
particular models the versions of the
models and now that data that we have in
our inference environment that data that
we don't have is not training data
because in many cases we're not going to
have well in suburb like in in
supervised learning
um you know having the labels uh in
order for us to actually then bring it
back into our data Ops World
we may need to have different
Transformations we may need to have
different information about the data
itself so that we can actually bring
value back into the data Ops World now
let's ask the question well what is the
metadata that is involved here in order
to achieve that that's the question of
this talk and why is it different
so uh you know in terms of like looking
at that we first want to see okay well
what are the limits of uh model metadata
in how we see it today and the way that
we I want to ask this question is what
are the limits of the concept of model
artifacts right because that's the
closest that we currently think of well
it's a generalization but let's just
think about like model artifacts that
say well this is how to manage metadata
well why is that not enough well so
let's see what are the resources that
you have first let's say that we have a
bunch of uh data instances from data set
a right so we have data instance A1 all
the way to data instance a n right this
could be like a row this could be like a
like a like a data instance right and we
basically train first a machine learning
Model A a machine learning artifact
Model A with this subset of their
instances right so now we have a model
artifact A1
and we do the same with different
subsets of our data set creating
different experiments right creating
different artifacts now this is the
challenge right when we actually want to
operationalize those machine learning
models
we don't just operationalize that model
and and that's where it finishes right
because the way that we do it right
whether we want to operationalize model
A1 A2 am or or model artifact B1 B2 B
and N
um when we actually operationalize them
in let's say an operational environment
we can actually deploy let's say or
operationalize model a artifact am into
environment CX but also into environment
Cy so what do we have now
we now have a one-to-many relationship
with our models right but what even if
we take it to the next level why do we
actually have a pipeline that that
actually uses uh this artifact am as a
preprocessor and then another artifact
as a post processor so now we basically
have a many-to-many relationship between
our model and our use of our model right
our blueprint and our instantiation
right so we have a many-to-many
relationship that has to be considered
when it comes to metadata right we no
longer can say okay well this artifact
has this properties and and that's it
right it's like now we have an
operational instantiation of this model
and we want to know if something goes
wrong where did this come from what was
the configuration and where else perhaps
it's being used
um so so I mean you know there's a
there's just some a subset of things but
but those are like an initial set of
challenges that we want to First tackle
so how do we tackle the um this deploy
model relationships so the way that that
we have initially tackled It Is by
ensuring that the operational component
is able to do two things the first one
it's able to actually uh be be sort of
deployed with any arbitrary metadata so
for example if you have a model that was
trained with DVC or with ML flow or with
Pachyderm or whatever you you would be
able to pass a set of like tags that
provide you with that unique identifier
the DVC identifier or the ammo flow
identifier that would actually be
embedded as part of this together with
any operational metadata that is part of
the model itself now the second part is
that this model metadata sorry this this
this
um this this uh service metadata or
machine learning service metadata
um can also be uh consumed by any uh
external systems that want to actually
push that metadata Upstream right that
means that you would be able to ask the
question of what are the digital assets
that I have available
but I have operationalized that I can
consume right this being able to
actually perform the the the key value
of metadata itself which is enrichment
so that I can have the data that I need
but more importantly discoverability is
what do I have out there as well as
lineage is what have I had out there
together with the reproducibility now
the key thing is that if we go back to
the initial premise which is that we're
now living in a best of breed
environment right an environment where
where we're going to bring in
um the best tool for the for the for the
craft
we have to make sure that each of these
systems are taking this principles by
Design and ensuring that they are
providing this metadata in a way that
allows for interoperability so what we
have done with with in this case our
system which is actually this production
deployment machine Learning System uh to
have kind of like pipelines running in
kubernetes called seldom core uh is
basically we've said look we will be
able to provide the the metadata that is
that is existing in this tool for
consumption or Upstream so external
metadata stores can ask the question of
hey what is running inside
and then can actually build those
taxonomies uh on top of that right so
that's a key thing so that was the first
challenge right like data relationships
now let's dive into the second challenge
that we talked about
when we're capturing the data
right the inference data no are like
static data however when I call it data
Ops data the inference data when we're
capturing it it may have a different uh
shape or schema how do we make sure that
all of this data uh is still consumable
is still is still fit for for use and
it's not just like uh binaries are
flying around and why is it why is this
a problem well this is a problem that we
want to address because whenever we are
actually productionizing machine
learning models we're no longer
productionizing just mm models we're
productionizing ml systems rarely now
you see organizations that are tackling
a particular you know large
um uh challenge that actually just
involves you know an iris classifier it
never has involved an iris classifier
but like like a simple machine learning
model if you look at a lot of the
production grade large scale machine
Learning Systems in this case for
example this is the uh Facebook search
architecture this has actually multiple
components right it has online
components offline components in this
case basically you have the offline
component that creates the the document
embeddings right it actually processes
kind of like uh an embedding space that
is quantized that then it's available so
that whenever you actually perform a
search
um you have kind of a query processing
then you have the retrieval that uses
that embedding and the ranking itself so
that you get your results right so this
is a complex machine Learning System
it's not just a model so with that
machine Learning System we have
different components that have to
interact with each other
and the challenge that we see here is
that whenever you deploy a machine
learning model at least previously each
of these machine learning Services
had a different schema a different input
schema and output schema how you
communicate with that how do you perform
inference so one of them the tensorflow
protocol it used to be in one shape the
mlflow protocol was another shape the
seldom protocol was another shape the
case of protocol was another shape and
the pytharch protocol was a binary right
you send a binary now it's no longer
because we actually have a great
um uh collaboration that has been
cross-industry which is basically the
creation of what we now refer to as the
open inference protocol so the open
inference protocol is basically a
protocol that has been adopted by
several of uh you know very kind of like
largely adopted uh machine learning
servers uh that that are currently used
in production to to deploy machine
learning models such as like torch serve
K serve uh seldom core Nvidia Triton uh
and even ammo flow because it uses ml
server or there's an ml server runtime
that you can adopt and basically what
this the reason why this is great is
because now that means that the data in
Flight is standardized right and this is
this is a great thing because now the
data in Flight can be consumed in a much
more standardized way and it can
actually be processed in a way that can
be much more meaningful uh for for
production machine learning use cases
and more specifically for
interoperability when creating machine
Learning Systems right with multiple
different stages now it doesn't stop
there right
because one what the first step is to
basically say hey what are the the
Baseline requirements to make sure that
we have a an aligned schema right so on
this schema it's great right because it
provides a standardized set of endpoints
for for not just the shape of the inputs
and outputs but also the functionality
it has a multimodal serving API for
management uh at the back end it has
capabilities for multiversion support
for models it has HealthPoint uh Health
endpoints and it has metadata endpoints
so it not only standardizes the the the
the data in Flight it also standardizes
the the functionality that it should
provide at the base minimum which is
which is great but the second thing is
once we are once we have the data over
here in our deployment how do we consume
it back into our experimentation or even
further into our data labeling right and
that is basically with what we actually
have been able to tackle which is now
that we have a standardized definition
of the data in Flight we can now come
come up with a schema that describes
that data right and the actual schema
basically allows you to specify is the
data that is sent to the model
um a real
um you know data instance is it
categorical what is the categories is it
a probability base is it a one-hot
vector it's a text is it a tensor and
that has actually been released uh to
you know ensure that you can extrapolate
for your pipeline so it's like if you
have this shape of inputs for each of
the steps now you can understand what
are your expected you know pipeline
inputs and pipeline outputs as well as
complex pipeline inputs and outputs and
even your complex machine Learning
System inputs and outputs at the
different stages
and we have been able to release this
under the name of the open inference
schema which is basically another
standard that actually Builds on the
open inference uh API uh uh that allows
you to be able to not just have a
standardized way of communicating
between servers but also being able to
actually uh convert this data into
machine readable uh formats which I
think is great and this is basically
self-explanatory you describe what the
input shapes are and that allows you to
be able to you know consume the data
that that is at flight
now finally just to kind of wrap up
there's a very important call to action
right is that yes it's great that these
things have been created but now what we
would want is to make sure that there is
further adoption of these standards and
there's further contribution to these
standards right it doesn't end here we
have we want to make sure that you know
whilst we're focusing specifically into
the productionization because that's the
projects that we maintain we need this
initiatives to to to to be similar for
all the other stages of the machine
learning life cycle so any practitioners
that are involved in other stages the
call to action is to also get involved
and driving forward some of those things
with the virus organizations such as the
Linux Linux Foundation as well as others
so with that uh you know uh today we
covered metadata systems for end-to-end
data and machine learning platforms uh I
hope you enjoyed the session once I get
as a reminder you can find the slides on
videoly slash metaop and with that uh I
hope you enjoy the rest of the
conference
um and I'll pause there
so thank you very much